this muddy wasteland of broken homes and
ash covered crops lies in the shadow of
indonesia's mount samiro volcano it
thundered to life on saturday shooting
clouds of ash into the sky
swallowing homes and blanketing entire
villages in grey
survivors say there was no warning and
that many people were killed
after the eruption my house was damaged
the ceiling destroyed i opened the door
it was so hot so i closed the door went
into the house but then i decided to
flee
many are now sheltering in evacuation
centers where they're given hot meals
and a temporary roof over their head
but indonesia's president says a more
long-term plan is necessary joko widodo
visited the disaster zone on tuesday his
government will now look into moving
homes away from the volcano because of
the threat of more eruptions
we hope that once everything has
subsided that everything can start
fixing infrastructure or even relocating
those from places we predict are too
dangerous to return to just now i
received a report saying that around
2000 families need to be relocated
immediately
mount samaro is the tallest mountain on
the island of java and one of nearly 130
active volcanoes in indonesia
people are being told not to travel
within five kilometres of the crater
because the air nearby is highly
polluted
evacuees complain about coughs brought
on by the dust and smoke while many in
hospital are suffering from burns from
the searing hot lava
when i came down from my truck i stepped
in the lava i ran and climbed onto the
roof of someone's house the volcanic ash
and smoke was choking i felt like i
couldn't breathe for 10 or 15 minutes i
don't know but thank god i was given a
chance to live
others weren't so lucky the body of a 13
year old boy was retrieved on monday the
rescuers are battling dangerous
conditions rain has turned debris into
thick mud and the lava is hardening
for now once bustling villages remain
empty and silent
people say they're too scared to go home
in case the volcano roars to life once
more
alex o'brien al jazeera